blind date
[Music]
you remember this show yeah this show
used to air all the time all day long
they used to reruns reruns they milked
the [__] out of that yes
hey everybody i'm roger lodge and
welcome once again to the party known as
blind day so let's go ahead and get
right to the action
and today we'll start with lauren and
bill now lauren's a student who says
she's never been in love but that's why
we're setting her up with bill he's a
film student who likes intimate 21 and
22 they look 45 but that's my point is
it just me it's crazy hold on is it just
me or did folks at our time and before
looked older than their ages cause
today's 20 year olds look
17 16. i got to ask [__] for
the idea a few times
[__] i don't believe you
yeah someone's [__] yeah they look
weird
like this guy looks like he's in his
late 20s late well mid-30s even yeah but
you know what i realized recently i was
watching like old football matches uh
european football um from like 2010
and the players just looked bigger and
also looked older
at a younger age and i think it was just
a different
different look for whatever reason yeah
yeah i definitely say my wild side comes
out after i have a few beers in me a
good kisser is key
if someone's a bad kisser
it won't work maybe it's also the
cameras yeah the cameras make look
everyone whatever also the style yeah
yeah
too much makeup too [__] of an outfit
total turn off i always go for guys with
a sense of humor but a girl that's
definitely honest is going to be blunt
with you and not play games that's a
turn on yeah i think i can be really
sarcastic at times i like a girl that is
definitely down to go out have a good
time have some drinks and just have fun
some laughs my friends would say i'm
socially uninhibited
oh yeah these two have definitely come
to the right they did it in 30.
why they did him dirty
opposite the trap yeah opposite
[Music]
where's my beer where's my beer
hi hi how are you doing good i'm bill
nice to meet you i'm sorry what's your
name lauren
[Music]
we're gonna be so wasted lauren nice to
meet you too
[Music]
they used to love these captions bro
they used to love these captions it was
great and the editing was crazy to make
everyone look stupid
that's how you like you sell it i love
it yeah it's a lot of fun where are you
guys ucla how you doing what uh what
year are you uh third year third year
maybe 10. me too me too so what do you
usually do for fun then do you usually
go to stories and frats or do you go out
to bars a lot i got about well now i'm
finally twenty one wait nice how old are
you 22. oh nice yeah i turned 21 in
january so i mean i had a fake id for
two years anyway so why why the hell do
you have a fake [__] d [__] you look 45
you can go through grandma go ahead have
some fun [__] until you until your hips
drop
you know what's crazy is that we're
going to put out this video and it's
probably 45 now
that's how old this [__] is
i'll be like four nights in a row
drinking for me
oh it'll be oh god like four weeks in a
row
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
actually no not really i moved down here
about 10 months ago and up until that
point i was always in like long
relationships i've been in a lot of long
relationships personally that's the
longest
that's how you massage bruh i think he's
auditioning to be a police officer
because then pat down to trash oh my god
that is one of the worst massages i've
ever seen doing my guy you don't know
what that listen if you're giving a girl
a good massage she should be laboring to
get the words out
she should be going um yeah
that's how it should be going did you
get a good massage
you got to take your breath away you got
you got a little moan here and there
yeah and then when you asking questions
you don't know what the hell you said
and if you hit a good pressure point
she'd be like
yes that's how it should be uh my last
one was about two and a half years oh my
longest relationship was four months
four and a half months actually four and
a half ooh that's too serious
the way he's grabbing the [__] thing
is like oh she's a little bit fat there
a little bit of fat and like you're not
doing nothing
[Music]
sweet thank you
all right thumbs up
[Music]
thank you
what's up
hey can we get uh some more saucy yeager
please
sweet
love you
what shots while you eat
you're degenerate
no i love hanging out with you really
cool girl hang out
get up get on it up get on the scene
outside
yes
the slurring on this yo so disgusting
it's more it's way more important to to
protect her than to please her who gives
a [__] about a woman's organs it's
useless right
no
wait a minute you said who gives a [__]
have a woman ever had an orgasm with you
yeah but i don't know like i'm not like
in there like like trying to like make
it happen i just like do it if it
happens awesome if it don't like turns
out it's not only myron's hair that's
missing but it's also a sex game and i
don't want that to be you guys most of
our viewers are men but i know that you
guys care about women's pleasure and
that's why with today's sponsor women's
toys are going to come into play because
you want the tool like a carpenter
don't think as sex toys as toys think of
them as tools
yeah
to reach the spot the same way that you
have a gps to go to your destination
well you need tools to get her to work
destination it's a tool that makes her
drool sometimes you're doing that
[Music]
you know all that
you know what i mean you flick the bean
copper on you ever ate her out
and then your jaw feels numb
maybe it's because you don't have the
proper tool you have all the good
intentions kudos to you but you need the
proper tool to make or drool that that's
why i'm glad that lilo is partnering
with us on this video to show you the
sila cruise sheila cruz is the best
thing that you can ever have to make her
jewel it's basically a sonic clitoral
massager imma get mine i sure hope you
get yours so get yours today in order
you know
you know click on the link below and
let's get it people not always just
funny like what else
this have to be entertaining for me
to hang out with and talk to you guys
yeah do you think i'm entertaining at
all or not
a little bit
let them swim
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know that's a big treaty what
started yeah
i think you might have been old white
man in your past life actually comes out
too natural
an old irish potato farmer lily potatoes
shot to you lauren
[Music]
hey uh can we get uh two more shots of
jaeger and some more margaritas
please blend it blend it blended
love you thank you
he's one of those
he's one of those drunk guys who gets
really touchy and really espresso yeah
yeah
love you love you thanks babe yeah love
you yeah they get very touchy
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah they're ready to blow this popsicle
stand and get some more booze
[Music]
[__] turn into an owl halfway through
oh
[Music]
no i just told you in general i'm not a
fan of
facial hair i'm just not oh come on you
love it musicals aren't
somebody has to shave my beard
[Music]
but can you kiss me if i shave my beard
can i get a shot in a razor please
some [__] really want to get
laid they'll do anything yeah you want
me to shave off my head to sniff your
[__]
uh can i get a barber and a yay like
they will do anything they would
oh
[Music]
beautiful you might keep going
that's whipped cream that's not shaving
cream
that's whipped cream
[Laughter]
hey oh
wow hey hey listen
enjoy your staph infection yo you're
gonna have some [__]
you're gonna have some pimples tomorrow
shaving with sugar bruv
i'm okay but if you cut me i swear
this is fine
back in the day we're crazy all right
listen guys
if you want to get your shaving done use
man's skate lawnmower four-point mask
that's just nasty
[Music]
okay you love it
you love it
smooth smoothing out the cast minute the
kiss
[Music]
okay
let's just do it let's just go looking
just yeah
you love it
i think you're very beautiful and very
sexy and attractive
booyah back at me what do you think what
do you think what do you think
what do you think we did
you're about to scan because you're a
smooth operator
smooth
operator
you love it
there's no way you brought up shawn
because i'm dude smooth operator
spills it on her and then goes
smooth
he finished his [__] course
oh this guy
what do you think of me what'd you think
of me booyah back at me and she's just
like
brother i'm gonna vomit bro
bruh that's like hitting the girl right
you banging y'all playing some rb and
it's just like i beat it up beat it up
on my dick soft i'm still going to try
to beat it up be that like no it you
killed it you're done it's over turn
change the song let's go
thanks
you love it
he's out of this
i just feel the trick on it you love it
you love it girls will say girl we'll
kiss you even though
they don't like you bro they'll they'll
kiss their way out of a situation i
understand that yeah
[Music]
she's grossed out by him yeah she's wet
but not for the right reason
that's a bar
like rev yeah he cut his hair he also
cut his chances of [__] yeah
where's my beer
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't look too happy right now
i don't know what's saying
you know what to say
[Music]
okay okay uh timberland
baby girl
what what what what what yeah yeah yeah
yeah no
[Music]
are you mad at me no
no
[Music]
wanna come inside and watch me puke
it's gonna it's not gonna be a kid she's
not trying to kiss him she's just trying
to
see me yeah sure
very beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
all right but you know what
smooth operator deserved shortly
yeah yeah yeah yeah no because you love
it
we love it you're about like no no no
but still you're like i love you
guess who you like
now i've seen a lot on this show but a
shaving
got to be another blind date first and
don't even think about changing that
channel because when we come back lauren
has some special dating advice for billy
boy and you don't want to miss it
up next i just refuse to kill myself to
live how to lose a girl in 10 minutes
it's kind of a boring existence but it's
my reality that's next
[Music]
because you're a smooth operator
you love it
there you have it folks that's why after
dinner we do the driving and something
tells me lauren didn't exactly love her
date with bill let's find out if i'm
right
bill i didn't love it lauren oh my gosh
she's so beautiful she's so hot when i
first saw belly seemed like he could be
a nice guy but his chin strap a facial
hair kind of threw me for a curve she's
beautiful she's nunned out she's a hot
girl after damn goddamn so that's what
dating shows used to be like
that was great and what do you guys
think do you guys love it
i love it you know it was like i love
him it's awful
and i love it too don't you love it
too many lines from this guy i think he
watches background listen cringe is like
crazy oh for sure i hope pro dip to you
guys if you guys want to do it then
don't drink that much goddamn good lord
jesus christ listen to what you guys
think in the comments below what do you
guys think about old dating shows when
we getting back wild i think we're
getting about wild we was how many shots
did this [__] take every of them